you are a clinical psychologist I'm a
clinical psychology you think toxic
masculinity is a lie I know toxic masks
you know and you also know that men
should not date feminists I'm fairly
well dependent we'll have to define turn
right so I thought there's a lot of
interesting something can talk about but
one of the most important things is the
it's the American psychologist
Association or American Psychological
Psychological Association the APA put up
these guidelines when was it like a year
ago yeah about 20 18 28 January 2019
they came up and it's basically a bunch
of doctors like psychologists and
they're well actually you explained it
you explained it so the American
Psychological Association is the
governing body for the practice of
psychology in the United States and it's
it's comprised of clinicians and
academics and they have a foot in both
worlds they have a foot in education and
training psychologists and they have a
foot in the clinical world which is
where I live where you deal with the
real problems and real people and they
put out a list of things saying like man
bad they have they periodically put out
treatment guidelines so they'll have a
treatment guidelines for schizophrenia
where they outlined best practices if
for schizophrenia and treatment
guidelines for oh I came across a really
interesting one a few few months ago it
was something it was some obscure
disease that has to do with your
internal organs and the APA put out a
set of treatment guidelines if you're
working for with people who have this
obscure disease okay so it's not unusual
that they put out treatment guidelines
they put out in January 18 January 2019
these guidelines for working with boys
and men and it is not a disease by the
way well all right yeah it's ten
guidelines for working with boys and men
and it is just dripping I mean
absolutely dripping with feminist
ideology and we should define feminism
at some point but I'm talking about
radical man-hating intersectional angry
organized feminism that comes out of
gender studies department and found its
way into all kinds of things like human
resources departments and other things
and the APA guidelines for working with
boys and men well they want to smash the
patriarchy there's the way to do it I
guess so yeah so let's let's let's
define
because I think it's fair to say I know
a lot of people might get mad the
feminists particularly that dominant
feminism today is radical it's like
far-left
authoritarian intersectional cancel
culture woke all of these things and
I've had conversations with you know
women who are like I'm a feminist
because I believe in the equality
between genders and I'm like that was
like 40 years ago right not even 40 of
them and maybe even longer than that
right so now you have I don't think it's
I guess we call it feminism but it's
something else
it's dogmatic intersectionality or
wolken asur something some people call
it a supremacist movement a gender
supremacist movement I don't think
that's too far in some cases not
certainly not in all cases but let me
let me lay out what I think real
feminism is can I tell you a story for
me okay so in June 2018 I'm sure you saw
the story's gender studies professor
named Susanna du noodle walters had an
editorial in The Washington Post called
why can't we hate men do you remember
that article I really do yeah okay so
when she made the case that you know the
usual case is about the gender pay gap
and things lots of complaints that have
been debunked you know dredging up
complaints from the 1800s and so forth
and she was making the case that any man
who occupies any position of power or
authority should step aside and just and
hand that over to a woman because their
women are entitled to hate us for the
way men have treated women over the
centuries and she uses phrases like you
we are entitled to hate you that's not
her precise phrasing but she uses that
that kind of phrasing and so back on
Twitter back then I posted some things
about this because I found it
interesting and I got a lot of feedback
from both sides and some of the feedback
I got was while she's not a real
feminist
and I thought to myself okay whoa what
is a real feminist so there seem to be
two camps because two women could
describe themselves as feminists and
mean two completely different things are
two men for that matter one could could
mean equality of opportunity and
responsibility and she could be sort of
joyful in her femininity and then
there's a soon as Suzanna Danuta walters
they could both call themselves
feminists and mean opposite things yeah
so what's the real
feminism so let's say that there are I
don't know 100 million women in America
who believe that feminism is about
equality and it's about a shared
responsibility and it's about taking
accountability for your choices in your
outcomes in a very positive view of
femininity and masculinity there might
be a hundred million women like that I
don't know but what do they accomplish
they accomplish nothing because they're
they're not organized but over here we
have this very small group of people who
are on campuses people like Susana dunno
Walters who were poisoning young minds
they're organized they're funded and
their ideas find their way into the
legal system they find their way into
treatment guidelines they find their way
into HR departments they obviously find
their way into the minds of young women
which is really unfortunate maybe we'll
talk about dating feminists later but so
what's the real feminism it is it the
feminism that is the feminism with a
large number that has no real effect
because there are diffuse interest or is
it the feminism that has real effects on
real people's lives to me that's the
real feminism this is the one that's
actually affecting people I completely
agree I can play that that was a great
way to put it I view it as the dominant
faction whether they're bigger or
smaller is completely irrelevant are the
funded and organised faction and they're
in medicine they're in universities
they're in you know movies video games
comics pop culture Taylor Swift just
came out some video that was you know
it's it's also I'm coming to the teller
thing trust me but it's like this weird
stereotypical or like caricature of a
real life she did this song called like
the man I think where she dresses up and
does this thing where she's a man and
she literally says something like I
wonder how far I would have gotten if I
was a man and I'm like Taylor you're
worth 360 million dollars she might have
made it to 361 yeah every sixth or she
might have made it to less because she's
an attractive woman that's a part of why
she is famous in the first place that's
that's probably the likely or scenario
is that she would not have prospered
quite as much yep
and what's interesting too is in you
know so she makes this video that
propagates these ideas that are I mean
at the very least completely exaggerated
at you know in the worst case they are
completely wrong this idea that in the
entertain
in industry she would have fared better
as a man and maybe as like a producer
she would have made a six-figure salary
but her whole life was was charmed from
a young age performing it you know
high-profile events went to Montessori
school having her stockbroker father pay
her way through everything and then she
made it and she made it because she's an
attractive white woman so I think it's I
think it's particularly funny that you
know as much as I don't like to play
into the racial stereotypes things that
they tend to do it does tend to be white
women who push these ideas I know if
you've seen the data on this they go
ahead they tend to be college educated
white women who make more than $100,000
a year who are pushing this particular
ideology and for some reason they're
making gains particularly I think with
you know your area of expertise is the
APA now creating I guess a clinical
guideline for how to treat the element
that is masculinity right so let's let's
let's let's dive into that and I made
the joke it's not a disease you said
something like hold on well according to
the APA it's a collection of traits that
amount to a disease like there's
stoicism which is bad according to them
there's competitiveness oh no Russian
yeah so stoicism stoicism well now that
philosophy but you know containing your
emotions that's a thought that was a
great thing I think that's fantastic
it's a useful thing everybody should
have the skill to some degree and you
know it can be taken too far but as far
as I'm calling it toxic what they've
done with these guidelines is they have
taken a lot of maladaptive coping
strategies like stoicism taken too far
so that might look like a guy who
refuses to articulate to himself or
anybody else that he's really struggling
with something so he hits the sauce and
he turns he becomes an alcoholic so that
would be stoicism taking to an extreme
that's a maladaptive coping right what
they've done is they've taken
masculinity and they've taken all these
maladaptive coping strategies and
they've balled them all up together and
conflated them to give the impression
that these maladaptive coping strategies
represent men we could do the same thing
with women who be just as absurd but
there are maladaptive coping strategies
that women are prone to like
prescription substance abuse
they do that a little more often than
men persons certain personality
disorders they do more often than men
martyring themselves you know victim
points yeah well or victim points but
even just legitimately not speaking
their own interest for their own
interests and so they end up kind of
angry at everybody around them that's
more of a feminine trait guys do that do
they do a little bit differently but we
could take all of these maladaptive
coping strategies that tend to correlate
and cluster around women and we can say
well that's that's toxic femininity but
that would be just as ridiculous saying
that you know a guy who is an alcoholic
is a representative of of masculinity
yeah well so now our psychologists
actually treating people based on this
stuff this is a scary thing okay so why
do these guidelines matter they matter
because the American Psychological
Association is the largest the word I'm
looking for we when a school gets just
on the tip of my tongue they approve
schools right accreditation
accreditation sorry about that
they're the largest accrediting body for
psychology training programs yes so even
though the the guidelines themselves
they don't affect someone like me
because I'm in private practice and I'm
not there's no law that says I have to
follow these guidelines but if you're a
training program and you want to remain
accredited which is really important
it's so important that your graduates
won't be taken seriously if you don't
have accreditation they'll have more
difficulty getting licensed they'll
definitely have trouble getting that
that postdoc job and so forth so if you
want your program to be accredited and
you want people actually come to your
program well guess what you better fall
in line and falling in line I have to
assume in this case means it means you
follow the APA guidelines because it's
an APA accreditation so the APA
guidelines for treating men and boys is
going to come into play when you're
treating men and boys in your training
clinic so the APA is in the position and
I can't tell you to what extent they're
doing this but I have watched people go
through ok organizations go through
accreditation review and everybody's
stressed as a very stressful event
because the APA is scrutinizing your
program very closely so they're in the
position to make sure that their
professors and supervisors are are
feeding this force feeding this ideology
this angry feminist ideology to their
students and that their students at
least while they're training are force
feeding this ideology to their clients
Wow and this is creepy stuff it is
creepy stuff and they even say I don't
forget which a guideline it is exactly
but they they openly say that when
psychologists impose this ideology on
their male clients that their male
clients are then more likely to go out
and support social justice causes if
they very openly advocate for
psychologists to push this ideology on
their on their clients and by the way
this is this is a flat contradiction to
the APA zone ethical guidelines the
first ethical guideline is principle a
beneficence and Munn non-maleficence and
it says that you don't use the clinical
relationship to advance your own agenda
well here's the APA using a relationship
to advance their political agenda and I
want to be clear that I find their
identity Rhian radical angry ideology to
be particularly damaging but I would
have the same stance if they were
advancing an ideology that resonated
with me it's not their place to use the
clinic and the classroom to tell people
what to think but that's exactly what
they're doing I don't know why I'm the
only one yelling about it but because
people are scared they'll show up with a
crowbar they'll show up with a bike lock
well and in my profession you if you
have a regular job I'm private practice
so I have my clients come to me they
seek me out but if I had a regular job
at a prison or some kind of you know or
already university I could be saying
these things Wow the thing about them
force-feeding the ideology down the
pipeline is creepy that's why it's scary
it is because it sounds like you've
basically got a bunch of people who are
you know to an effect you know
understanding their being basically
jammed in a machine to shape their their
minds and bodies in this creepy way and
it's moving through them
but it is it's like there's this
nefarious faction of people and it's
almost like they're jamming or a round
peg through a square hole or you know
square peg through a round hall just
smashing it with a hammer to make it go
through in the hopes that there's gonna
be some ten year old kid who hears it
and just says okay because the next
generation so so the way I see it is the
people won't speak up at least in my
opinion because they know that someone
might show up and say you're fired
someone might show up with a black mask
and a crowbar and say you're a fascist
so they just say you got it but those
kids hear it on uncritically and so
they're believing it all now and maybe
that's the goal they can bend you into
submission you they'll fire you they'll
come for your job but as long as you say
what they want you to say the kids will
believe it and those kids will embrace
it wholeheartedly when they're your age
well and and this message from the APA
that talks that masculinity is toxic
it's really destructive free for boys
and young men because one of the things
that that went along with these
guidelines was there is an article that
got a lot of press is an article in the
APA monitor which is a magazine
basically do a little bit of research
but talking about what's going on the
profession what's going on APA so when
they release these guidelines a few
months later than they put out this
article and there was a line in the
article that got a lot of plane had said
the toxic masculinity which is defined
by stoicism competitiveness aggression
or or sorry masculinity which is
characterized by toxic or biown stoicism
competitiveness aggression I forget the
four terms they use but it was those
four things that it is on the whole
harmful so what they're saying is that
masculinity is harmful because it's
characterized by these things and so if
you're a young man and you're getting
this message you're not probably not
reading the APA monitor but you're
getting it from your teachers maybe your
parents buy into it maybe you have
unfortunately some kind of brush with
mental health system and you're getting
it from there you're getting from these
these sources that masculinity is toxic
that's a very shaming message and I
gotta tell you there's there's nothing
more dangerous than a man who has taught
to be repulsed by himself that's the man
that goes out and does the things
that the APA is saying all men do that's
the man that's truly dangerous because
he hates himself and so he's gonna make
sure that the rest of the world pays for
that I want to make sure we have
something absolutely clear too because I
know that we said basically you know in
the title I say toxic masculinity is a
lie but this article in The New York
Times says traditional masculinity right
so this is this that this is what's so
you know disconcerting to me I guess is
that we first started hearing toxic
masculinity
no no masculinity is fine toxic
masculinity is bad all the Twitter
feminist art saying all these men organ
about hurt we're not targeting
masculinity we're targeting toxic
masculinity and then once they weaseled
their way and enough they started saying
well right but traditional masculinity
is rooted in some toxic behaviors right
now here we are straight-up traditional
masculinity bed right it's a concept
tree right they get out foot in the door
and then they they just up the ante a
little bit more all the time yeah now
it's it's masculinity in general that is
a disease have you saw the Gillette
commercial I imagine yes yeah so what's
one of the ways I think they creep this
idea is so they show some things that
are objectionable bullying for instance
like yeah nobody likes bullying you know
do it to a certain degrees you know
there's a I think there's a scale
between kids roughhousing and being you
know a bit aggressive and kids being
direct bullies and actually punching a
gate or hurting them but what boys need
horseplay right it's a requirement so
you know look when I I think there's
there's a there's an imbalance between
one kid who's too much of a bullying one
kid who's too weak and that causes
problems goes out of control but when I
was a kid we had competition we had
conflict and we learned how to resolve
that and with within certain reason you
know I had a kid who picked a fight with
me and you gotta learn to stand up for
yourself you know be mature it doesn't
mean fight it means these are these are
conflict if to learn how to deal with
but anyway I digress so there's things
the commercials week we absolutely can
find objectionable but there was one
part where a guy is leaning up against
the wall and a woman walks past him and
he he makes like that face and then some
guy stops him and says no don't do it
and I'm like that to me was part of the
ideological creep in that they have now
started conflating talking with a
stranger like meeting
new person with harassing a person yes
so there was also that video 10 hours of
walking through New York as a woman
where you literally had them complaining
that a guy said how's it going and now
that's where they start conflating a guy
who yells you know hollering at a girl
saying gross things and a guy keeping
his head and saying ma'am so you know
that the crazy thing to me is if you
literally can't walk up to another woman
and say hi I just want to introduce
myself and trying to meet new people we
got to talk that's toxic masculinity
they have now literally it's not just
about masculinity they've not toxified
basic human behavior and force you to
repress all everything you do and then
I'm not surprised to find that guys
become reclusive locked themselves away
like you said it's the people who are
told to be repulsed by themselves that
do the crazy things you know do you know
what reset the clock is no I don't want
to deviate too much from the APA stuff
until we can move in the next segment
but there's a meme called reset the
clock what do we do and we reset the
clock days since a male feminist
sexually assaulted a feminist or women
say that again a male feminist days so
the clock is days since a male feminists
sexually assaulted a woman has it ever
been past zero well I mean yes but is
that's one that's the meme right it's
they say that whenever the story comes
out because so many have come out and so
there's something interesting it's like
why is it that the men who are more
likely to buy into all this stuff seem
to be more likely to attack these women
and I think it was Patton Oswalt the
comedian who said male feminists abusing
women is this generations Republican you
know anti-gay Republican turning out to
be gay and so I wonder if there's some
if that fits in with like the way you
what you're saying you have these men
who buy into this we also have this meme
I mean it may not be related but
certainly we're seeing something like
this has even been pointed out by some
comedians is that kind of an in the line
of with what you were kind of saying
about Mad well repulsed by themselves
and yeah it could be there could be a
couple things going on there that could
be just that you know I've seen what
appears to me to be men who are
pretending to be feminists right right
get what they want
yeah I think I don't know what
percentage is but I think that that
factor
but yeah you and when you shame men and
you shame normal interactions like I
could I can picture that scene from
Gillette right all right like what is
the reason I can picture it is because
it was so outlandish the guy made an
expression that nobody makes and right
control sorry I keep put a tag on that
yeah it's like I was saying at the
Taylor Swift video they've created this
fictional reality of what they think is
actually happening and then tell these
young people this is real life is like
never happens man
yeah yeah but but I don't know I don't
want to poll every trying to follow no
you didn't and it's what's so intriguing
about the APA because they do have one
foot in the clinical world and they're
dealing with real people and I don't
know how you have this this ideology
that says half the people are mentally
ill just by default because of their
chromosome arrangement and work with
those people
that's why the clinicians that I know
that I associate with a lot of
clinicians that work on the real world
they're in the trenches they don't have
that ideology because they're working
with real people and it's really hard to
hate a group of people when you're
working with them dealing with them on a
day to day basis I'm finding out that
hey you know people struggle like
everybody else struggles they're
demonizing basic masculine behaviors
that to me this stoicism thing is the
crazy thing aren't we like proud of
likes stoicism like it's typically a
positive thing
well I'm wrong about this yeah there's a
use for it and I'll give you an example
of the use of you know where the
masculine and the feminine really play
off nicely each other so imagine you're
you're driving down the highway and a
family's driving this sorry family's
driving on the highway you got a mother
father a couple kids in the backseat and
tire blows right so it's raining outside
it's cold the tire blows everybody's
upset so the mother is going to be very
stoic in that situation I guess
typically in traditional masculinity the
kind of masculine that the APA hates the
man would go out and start changing the
tire and so you have this man who's out
there stoically changing the tire and
demonstrating to his family hey it's
under control it's cool maybe at the end
if he's a really skilled father he's
joking about it and he's lightening the
mood for everybody that's the stoicism
and and the mother stays behind and she
makes sure that
everybody is emotionally safe again in
this traditional mapping write
additional mess she's making sure that
everybody's safe and comfortable and
meanwhile that the the stoic toxically
masculine man is out there fighting the
wolves - he's only changing a tire but
you get my point he's out in the cold
and in the wilderness and in dealing
with things this reminds me of a story I
read in a magazine there was a family
that was on the beach when I don't
remember exactly where was it may have
been the Northwest something but black
wolf emerges from you know walking down
the beach and the family father the
mother and the two kids swim out to a
rock not too far away and are shivering
and huddling in fear as the wolf paces
back and forth and I was thinking about
that story I'm like what would have
happened a couple hundred years ago
would the father have been armed what do
you know if he was taking his family for
an outing would he have been armed and
would even said stand behind me and then
drawn his blade to combat the wolf yeah
have we be you know I was thinking I
thought of a lot about certain things
about they're kind of good in a lot of
ways we don't wear our armor anymore
this is a good thing right comfortable
it's itchy yes but we were really
concerned that you know a bandit would
lurk in the forest and attack you and
these things still kind of happen but
and and to an extent there's kind of bad
things like one of the reasons we all
wear our Marines more is because weapons
have the advanced to a point where he'd
be pointless but we don't for the most
part we don't drive in tanks though you
don't drive in tanks we don't wear
bulletproof vests we don't most most
people in most urban areas don't need to
carry weapons though that can be debated
by a lot of people I think there's a
with they're still parts of the country
where this is still a concern but we've
really progressed to a point where we
don't have you know I don't want to act
like men aren't stoic and aren't big
defensive cuz you brought up a good
example of keeping calm and changing the
tire but it's very different forming
attacked by a bear when your family was
out living in the you know movenote
middle of nowhere or at least in the
wilderness as a pioneers men or
something so you can see like the
drastic difference between how the
world's used to be you know back a
couple of years ago everybody was
walking around armed to the teeth yeah
today people walk around in t-shirts but
in that in that same sense we are still
on the track it seems towards leaving
behind the survival capability of one of
which is remaining calm yes I have a
textbook a an introductory psychology
textbook is from 1949 a friend of mine
gave this to me a long time ago and it
is written like at a high school level
it seems like it's so the language is
pretty pretty basic and it's introducing
some very basic concepts but it talks
about character which is something that
my profession doesn't really talk about
much anymore is character and under
character you see these traits that um
it's it's kind of comically masculine
like one of the things they talked about
they forgot the exact word they use but
it's the word - it was that word
contemporaneously that the word they
used back then to describe stoas
is staying keeping your emotions under
control they had a couple paragraphs
about the value of being able to stay
calm while everything around you is
falling apart so tire blows and it's
raining out you keep cool you go out you
handle it alright so we my profession
has gone from that being of value that
is worth teaching ya kids to now it's
it's mentalism so there's there's a
another story I like to reference I
don't remember exactly where I read this
but they said that there was a US
military a Navy naval vessel that was or
maybe it may have been a small army ship
was was sunk damaged and the you know US
servicemen got on a raft and they credit
the survival of this group because one
of the men took out his service weapon
dismantled it piece by piece and took
out every bullet and gave each
individual a single piece and then said
remember what your job is this is yours
this piece is yours we're gonna rebuild
this weapon and then they went one at a
time and they said this structured this
simple practice took people off panic it
gave them a more structured frame of
mind helped calm them down and they
credit that with the ability to form a
plan to ration to survive I don't know
if it's true or if it was an example I
was reading in a book about panics
survival in panic so if you have you
know a family and the father and I think
I think anybody can be so the mother can
be calm and rational help survive yes
and that's why I'm surprised that this
is a good thing and it's not a it's not
a masculine trait stoicism is not a
right men men may act it out more than
women in certain contexts but women do
it too what would happen if that tire
exploded and they skidded in there in
the middle of the Pacific Northwest and
that storm it's almost it's getting late
it's cloudy and the mother and the
father both start crying and panicking
and the kids are sitting the back crying
and panicking and then but nobody's a PA
that would be perfectly healthy the
response
well he's letting on his emotions
they're gonna die but at least they feel
better about themselves right yeah
thanks for checking out this segment
from the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the
show every Monday through Friday at 8
p.m. sometimes an hour or two and we do
have a full live recorded version of the
show that includes a lot of comments and
smaller segments you probably don't see
if you want to check that out you can
watch live at 8 p.m. Monday through
Friday or become a member of this
channel and for five bucks a month you
get full access to all of the recorded
podcasts every day after the show we
make them available in the community
section of this YouTube channel so don't
forget to subscribe and stick around for
more segments and more shows Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m.
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all in the next show
you